[Aplausos]
hola qué tal para mí es un gusto estar
con todos ustedes y compartirles un
poquito de mi historia y cómo el deporte
impacto mi vida de muchas maneras y todo
comenzó a los 9 años en unos cursos de
verano al principio me encantaba ir a
jugar voleibol porque podía jugar con
niñas igual de altas como yo pero fue
hasta los 12 años cuando esa manera de
pensar cambió participe en mi primer
campeonato nacional de voleibol
representando mi estado de coahuila en
ese nacional estaban los equipos de
todos los estados de diferentes
categorías y recuerdo mucho que mis
compañeras me decían mira eso niña está
en la selección de méxico mira ella
también está en la selección yo sea guau
yo quiero jugar como ellas y yo quiero
algún día representar a mi país en unos
juegos olímpicos regresa de ser nacional
súper motivada y no podía creer que al
año siguiente me convocaran para la
selección de méxico a los 13 años
obviamente en aquel entonces era banca
de la banca verdad
pero para mí era una experiencia
increíble porque tenía la oportunidad de
entrenar con las mejores jugadoras de mi
país y además podía ver a otros equipos
de otros países competir en vivo en
aquel entonces el equipo de cuba este
eran las tricampeonas olímpicas entonces
qué motivación verles jugar en vivo
porque para mí era un aprendizaje podía
ver sus movimientos como lo hacían y yo
regresara al entrenamiento y tratar de
imitarlos
a los 16 años ya estuve en el cuadro
titular de la selección participando en
un mundial en alemania quedando como la
mejor anotadora de la primera ronda
a los 17 años me acuerdo estar con mi
papá estábamos viendo televisión
estábamos viendo las finales de la liga
colegial de eeuu estaba jugando a la
universidad de stanford contra la
universidad de long beach en la
universidad de stanford estaba esta
jugadora logan tom que era la única
jugadora universitaria que participó por
eeuu en los juegos olímpicos de sydney
yo estaba viendo esos partidos y
volteaba con mi papá decía papá yo
quiero estar ahí yo quiero estar con las
mejores yo pensé que mi papá me decía
que esta niña está loca verdad sin
embargo el tío y me dijo por qué no
échale ganas porque no es a esas
palabras porque no se quedaron tan
grabadas dentro de mí a lo largo de toda
mi carrera
/ nada dos veces al día después de clase
después de hacer mi tarea tenía tanta
hambre y mi objetivo bien claro que era
lo que quería que solamente necesitaba
una oportunidad para poder demostrar que
podía hacerlo este año participé con un
equipo de coahuila en un campeonato
nacional de primera fuerza quedando
campeones y como premio nos llevaron a
puerto rico a un torneo amistoso ese ese
torneo fue muy importante para mí porque
conocí a una de las personas clave en mi
vida
larri este hombre me vio jugar en puerto
rico y me invitó a jugar a su equipo en
ponce en la liga profesional de puerto
rico en aquel entonces yo tenía 17 años
entonces mi respuesta fue bueno tengo
que pedirle permiso a mis papás
y segunda de no quiero que me pagues yo
lo que quiero es que me des una beca
para terminar me preparo porque yo
quiero irme a eeuu
y yo pensé al ser un dueño de una de un
equipo profesional pues me iba a decir
que no sin embargo fue hasta torreón a
hablar con mis papás pedirles permiso
porque él creía que tenía el potencial
para lograrlo
entonces después de seis meses en puerto
rico- cumplí mi sueño me ofrecieron una
beca para estudiar en la universidad del
sur de california y me convertí en la
primera jugadora mexicana en primera
división de la enee se doble a
esos cuatro años fueron una experiencia
increíble al principio fue muy difícil
adaptarme al cambio de cultura al cambio
de idioma usted los juro yo regresaba al
dormitorio de clases y decía y estoy tan
cansado de pensar en inglés sin embargo
tuve muchas compañeras que me apoyaron
muchísimo tuve compañeras de diferentes
nacionalidades diferentes culturas
diferentes historias y me di cuenta que
el deporte pues une une a las personas y
no importa que pienses diferente siempre
y cuando trabajes en equipo para un solo
objetivo y dentro de esos cuatro años
además de ganar dos campeonatos
nacionales obtuve una licenciatura en
comunicación y periodismo y yo creo que
es posible combinar los estudios con el
deporte si se hace de manera
disciplinada y sobre todo con mucho
apoyo
cuando termine mi carrera universitaria
tomé la decisión no es importante de mi
carrera deportiva
por un lado me habían ofrecido jugar en
la liga profesional de italia en aquel
entonces era la mejor liga del mundo
para jugar voleibol
y por otro lado tenía esta niña de 12
años que le había prometido ir a unos
juegos olímpicos entonces lo que hice
fue escuchar mi corazón y no defraudar a
esa niña por esta razón decidí cambiarme
de voleibol de sala al voleibol de playa
una disciplina que nunca había hecho en
mi vida
cuando decidí cambiarme al voleibol de
playa
muchas gentes entrenadores directivos
incluso compañeras me dijeron
viviana estás cometiendo el peor error
de tu vida viviana falta un año y medio
para los juegos olímpicos no lo vas a
lograr incluso nos decían viviendo estás
muy hasta para jugar voleibol de playa
porque moverse en la arena es difícil
sin embargo yo sabía que eso era
exactamente lo que quería y así fue como
conocí a mi compañera mayra garcía y a
mi entrenador salvador gonzález nos
mudamos en mazatlán empezamos de cero
pero con la convicción de que era lo que
queríamos les confieso al principio
hasta yo mismo dije bibiana que estás
haciendo aquí tú eres de torreón allá ni
hay playa
me tropezaba en arena
sin embargo mi compañera y mi entrenador
fueron muy pacientes conmigo ya base de
mucha disciplina mucho esfuerzo y sobre
todo nunca dejar de creer que lo
podíamos lograr
logramos nuestro objetivo un año y medio
después el día 8 de agosto del mes 8 del
año 2008 a las 8 de la noche
/ por ese túnel a la inauguración de los
juegos olímpicos de beijing
les puedo platicar
más bien no tengo palabras para decirles
lo que se siente estar en ese evento
pero si les aseguro que todo el esfuerzo
y todo lo que los obstáculos que pasamos
valieron la pena y no hay duda que lo
volvería a hacer
regresando de beijing tome la decisión
de iniciar una maestría aquí en el tec
de monterrey y para mí fue una
experiencia única porque
tuve la oportunidad de d
y transmitir mi experiencia con unas
nuevas compañeras que fueron muy
abiertos a escucharme y entender que el
deporte como el voleibol es un deporte
de conjunto y cada una es una pieza muy
importante para lograr un objetivo
y es por eso que en el tiempo que estuve
aquí en el tec logramos cuatro
campeonatos nacionales dos en voleibol
de sala y dos en volibol de playa y esto
es algo que siempre se quedará en mi
memoria
si continúa jugando ocho años más
voleibol de playa hasta que ha decidido
retirarme hace dos años y comencé a
trabajar en la dirección atlética y
deportiva aquí en el tec
algo que me apasiona y me encanta de mi
trabajo es que tengo esa oportunidad
ahora de transmitírselo a nuestros
estudiantes
y decirles que el deporte te abre
puertas a muchas cosas y te abre algunas
puertas a una mejor educación y si
tienes un objetivo claro y trabajas para
eso puedes lograr lo que quieras
meses después de que yo empecé a
trabajar recibí y tuve un partido más
pendiente en mi vida que tenía que
afrontar
a los pocos meses de empezar a trabajar
me diagnosticaron cáncer
al principio no sabía cómo tomarlo pero
sabía que era un reto más en mi vida
estoy totalmente convencida que el
deporte me dio las herramientas que yo
necesitaba para enfrentar esta
enfermedad
me dio la autodisciplina
me enseñó a creer en mí
me enseñó a levantarme caer y levantarme
de los malos momentos y sobre todo me
enseñó a trabajar en equipo en este caso
con mi familia con mis amigos y mis
compañeros de trabajo y hoy puedo
decirles que hemos ganado ese partido
así que por último solamente quiero
decirles que en el camino nos podemos
encontrar a muchas personas que nos
pueden decir que no podemos hacer las
cosas tal vez porque ellos en su momento
le intentaron y no pudieron pero no
significa que ustedes no lo puedan saber
entonces cada vez que alguien les diga
que no pueden acuérdense de mi papá y
digan porque no muchas gracias
[Aplausos]